ALAN ARCHULETA. ATKINS EIGHTIES
OCCUR PORGES BRADFORD COME BY
ADAM CORTESE DALLEY DIED THE
RHIZOME AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTS BERG WEST SO HER
TADO JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED.
EVA LEE MON MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF
BOGUS HAN FORTUNE TINO RAW
RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER WILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
NOT PRESENT. WHAT THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER HIS
MORNING BY SENATOR CALM WATER.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASHEN
REMAINS STANDING AND WILL BE
LED AND PLEDGE BY SENATOR DODD
SENATOR COLLAR. THANK YOU.
PRAYER IN POWER. SILENCED HANDS
AND HEART OPEN I PRAY. BRUSH
AWAY WHAT KEEPS ME STOCK DULLED
BY FIGURING NOT LISTENING TO
YOUR PRESENCE YOUR WORDS WHAT
AM I LOOKING FOR EXPECTING TO
SEE. LIKE THE BANKS OF A RIVER
I NEED TO WAIT READY TO RECEIVE
SACRED LIFE AND READY TO LET GO.
JESUS SPENT NIGHTS IN PRAYER
SPOKE THE UNEXPECTED TO
FOLLOWERS THAT SUFFERING
STRANGER THEY CANNOT NIGHT
WOMAN WHO KNEW SHE BELONGED
WATCHED AND WAITED SAW THE
LIGHT OF JESUS'S COMPASSION.
FALL IN FOR THE MOMENT WITH
TIREDNESS AND MISUNDERSTANDING.
SHE BELIEVED LOVE WOULD PREVAIL.
TUNED TO YOUR RHYTHMS OH GOD
GIVE US OUR EYES TO SEE INTO
THE SHADOWS WERE HOLINESS LIVES
INVISIBLE IN QUESTIONS
UNCERTAINTIES WITHOUT ANSWERS
WE DWELL IN MYSTERY CONNECTION
COMMUNION YOUR HEART BEAT
EVERYWHERE A MAN. WITH LIKE DAY
FOUR DAYS AWAY PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG I PUT.
YEAH THIS IS ALL. S. R. O.
THANK YOU MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
WE HAVE QUITE A FEW ITEMS SO WE
NEED TO GET ABOUT THE BUSINESS
OF OUR DAY AND WE'RE LUCKY WILL
BE OUT BY NOON. ALL RIGHT I CAN
MAKE SURE PEOPLE PAYING
ATTENTION- BUT BEFORE WE START
I REALIZE WE HAVE TWO BIRTHDAYS
WOULD LIKE TO QUICKLY RECOGNIZE
THAT HERE IT'S SENATOR DODD'S%
BIRTHDAY SO LET'S. WISH SENATOR
DODD I HOPE HAPPY SAID IT.
BIRTHDAY AND I. ALSO HERE IT'S
OUR MARVELOUS- SENATE STAFF
TANIA MARSHALL'S- BIRTHDAY SO.
AND I GOT IT FROM A GOOD SOURCE
IS NOT RIGHT THAT STUDENTS
LATER H. ME SHE SAYS. BUT THEY
TELL ME IT'S OUR TWENTY NINE SO
LET'S WISH HER A HAPPY TWENTY
NINTH BIRTHDAY TANIA MARSHALL.
AND FOR SENATOR DODD ALL WE
KNOW IT'S BEEN A HELL OF A
TIMES THAT YOU'VE SET
CELEBRATED BIRTHDAYS SO. WE
WILL BEGIN MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEE MARET.
MOSES FROM THIS CERTAINLY WILL
BE DOING READ. REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEES WILL BE DOING READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
OR RESOLUTIONS. DO WE HAVE
MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS. WE HAVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG UNDER MOTIONS
OR RESOLUTIONS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I MOVE THE
ADOPTION OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
FOR BUDGET BILLS THAT CROSS THE
DESK ON FRIDAY SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY JUNE ELEVENTH JUNE
TWELFTH TO JUNE THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
PUBLISHED AND THE MEASURES
RETURN TO COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU. SENATOR
NELSON. HI JACK REQUESTED ROLL
CALL VOTE NO NO OKAY NO
UNANIMOUS CONSENT HER RIGHT.
SENATOR HERTZBERG CAST FOR ALL
VOTE SOONER NELSON'S ASKING FOR
NO VOTE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER DESCRIPTION A BIT ON
THE SIDE OF. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. I FACE NO BACKER.
HI PORGES NO BRADFORD. FIVE BY
ADAM HI COURTESY HI DALLY. NO
DOG. I TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS
NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN WATER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. HI THE MON I MEAN WHY
ARE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
I AM BERG HI WHAT KASKY. I
WINNER I WILL NO THE- WAY SO HI.
FIVE THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. THE MOTION
CARRIES- MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OTHER MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS AT
THIS TIME CHERYL BURKE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE FIVE SEVEN NINE FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. GOING ON.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO THIS CONSIDERATION-
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE SENATE
SECOND READING MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX SIXTY THREE WITH AMENMENTS
THIRTEEN TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE THIRTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU NOW MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. ARE WE
READY WITH GOVERNANCE APARTMENT
CENTER BATES. WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
YES SIR WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH IS A
CONFIRMATION OF OUR MONDO
QUINTERO AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION MR CAN TERREL HAVE
AN EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND IN PARK
MANAGEMENT AND WAS ALSO
PREVIOUSLY AND ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS- CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION. HE
WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
SEVENTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THE DESCRIPTION IS BASED
ON THIS APPOINTMENT CENTER
RECORD. YOU SHOULD SHARE JUST
WANTED TO RISE BRIEFLY TO I
SAID THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH AMANDA QUINN TERO FOR MANY
YEARS MANY STRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT YOU SIMMER SAID
RIGHT HERE THAT FOUNDATION
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND- LATER
WITH THE RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN
THERE- HE'S VERY. KNOWLEDGEABLE
A DEDICATED AND I THINK HE WILL
SERVE EXCELLENT JOB RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON. THIS PRESS LATE IN JUNE
SAID I CERTAINLY URGE AND I
VOTE ON DIRECTOR CAN TERO HE
HAS A LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
CAREER IN BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE AUTHORITIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES CERTAINLY
KNOWS THIS AREA IS WELL
QUALIFIED TO DO THE JOB HE IS
PERSONABLE. AND I WOULD URGE
AND I BOTH ARE MONDO CAN TEAR.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MR MR PRESIDENT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL PARKS IN THE WORLD
AND MANY OF THOSE PARKS ARE
STATE PARKS SO THIS THIS
PARTICULAR APPOINTMENT IS
PARTICULARLY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART BECAUSE OF MR CAN GET
AWAYS FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE NEED
FOR PARK PARKS STATE PARKS IN
PARK POOR COMMUNITIES AND THEY
NEED TO CONNECT OUR PARK SO
THAT VISITORS TO THE STATE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO VISIT OTHER
PLACES OR PLACES OTHER THAN
JUST THE COASTAL REGION AND SO
I RISE IN SUPPORT I THINK HE'S
GOING TO BE HE'S GOING TO DO A
TREMENDOUS JOB FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL. I
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES. MR KANTOR-
COUPLE OF TIMES AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HIS. NOMINATION FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS POINT TO POINT. HERE NINE
CENTER VETERANS OUGHT TO CLOSE.
AS FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I'M SIX GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. BASED FIVE BECKER
HI PORGES I BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM HI COURTESY HI DALLY. HI
DODD FIVE TORONTO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER. HI CONSOL IS HIGH
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON FIVE WIRE. HI MELINDA'S.
MAN HI NEWMAN I NELSON HI A
SHOW OF BOTH. I PANNED BY
FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. STERN HI NUMBER
FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI HI WINNER
FIVE WELL HI. MMHM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THAT'S A MEMBER. AT
KINS HI. MELINDA'S SKINNER.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
FOREMAN IS CONFIRMED NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON A FALL ITEM SEVEN
CENTERBRIDGE. BY LINE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF RYAN BROOKS AND
ALEJANDRO. CAMPOS VERITY FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND DR RANDY HAWKINS AND
LORI ROZSA LUCIANO FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD MR BROOKS MISS CAMP HILL
BEARD- MISS LUCIANO OUR PUBLIC
MEMBERS. AND DOCTOR HAWKINS
SERVES AS PHYSICIAN MEMBER ON
THE BOARD THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY TWELFTH ON A UNANIMOUS
FIVE ZERO VOTE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU IN FOR THE DESCRIPTION OF
THE RAID ON THESE APPOINTMENTS
CENTER PATH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS- I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THESE
NOMINEES BUT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO MAKE AN OBSERVATION BEFORE
WE VOTE- WELL CERTAINLY THE
CHARGE OF THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC- THEREFORE
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
MEMBERS OF THE MEDICAL BOARD-
NOT ONLY THE PHYSICIANS BUT
ALSO THE PUBLIC MEMBERS- MAKE
THEM. AVAIL THEMSELVES TO BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE STANDARD OF
CARE AND ALSO OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT MEMBERS
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD. SPEAK
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. SO HI WITH THAT- I
THINK THAT'S THE EXPECTATION I
HOPE TO SEE FROM OUR MEDICAL
BOARD MEMBERS AND INCLUDING OUR
PUBLIC MEMBERS. AND WITH THAT
THEY WOULD ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING C.
NINE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS. BASE HI BACKER. HI
PORGES FIVE BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
HI COURTESY HI DALLY I DONT HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN HI LASER.
HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG HI WHERE SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. HI WE MOAN HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF
BOTH I PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
HI NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI. M. SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS MELINDA'S SKINNER. HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IT ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
NUMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING IS NOW SIT
AT THIRD READING WE HAVE FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR GONZALES
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT. SO
OR CENTERED PROGRAM STARTS IN
HER SPORT ARE YOU PREPARED I
SEE YES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG RELATIVE TO
SUKI HANA BI SAYS DAY. IN ORDER
TO WORK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WINNERS SCANNER GONZALES SEARCH
FOR. PRITCHETT THAT OUR MEMBERS
ATTENTION PLEASE BECAUSE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT TO A- IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION WE ALL REMEMBER SOME
YEARS AGO. HI GUYS BUT WE ALL
REMEMBER SOME YEARS AGO. BY THE
EXTRAORDINARY STORY THAT STEVEN
SPIELBERG TOLD HIS MOVIE
SCHINDLER'S LIST. ABOUT OSKAR
SCHINDLER. IN HIS HERO WORK
EFFORTS SAVE MORE THAN TWELVE
HUNDRED JEWISH FAMILIES. FROM
THE **** CONCENTRATION CAMPS BY
EMPLOYING THEM IN HIS FACTORY.
TODAY HI RISE. TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION WHO HONORS JUNI
CIGAR. HE IS WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY HERO WITH GREAT
HUMILITY IN SAVING THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF JEWISH
REFUGEES FROM ADVANCING HITLER
ARMIES. WHEN HE DIED IN JAPAN.
IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. HE WAS
SO HUMBLE THE ONLY ONE A LARGE
JEWISH DELEGATION FROM AROUND
THE WORLD. INCLUDING THE
ISRAELI AMBASSADOR TO JAPAN
ATTENDED HIS FUNERAL. HIS
NEIGHBORS KNOW WHAT HE HAD DONE.
HARA SERVED AS VICE COUNSEL FOR
THE JAPANESE EMPIRE OF JAPAN IN
LITHUANIA DURING THE SECOND
WORLD WAR. FOLLOWING THE GERMAN
INVASION OF POLAND ON SEPTEMBER.
ONE NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF JEWISH
REFUGEES FROM POLISH AND POLISH
CITIZENS FLED EASTWARD AHEAD OF
THE ADVANCING GERMAN ARMIES.
OPTIONS FOR ESCAPE. WE'RE
LIMITED. AND REQUIRED
DIPLOMATIC VISAS TO CROSS
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS.
DESPERATE FOR A WAY OUT A LARGE
NUMBER OF JEWISH REFUGEES
GATHERED AT THE JAPANESE
CONSULATE IN LITHUANIA. SEEKING
TRANSIT VEHICLE LEASES TO ALLOW
THEM TO PASS THROUGH JAPAN TO
TAKE REFUGE IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
SHE HARD OVER TWO THOUSAND V.
SEARCH FOR ANY JEWISH PERSON
WHO SHOWED UP AT HIS OFFICE HE
REPORTEDLY SPENT TWENTY HOURS A
DAY IN A ONE MONTH PERIOD OF
TIME READING IS MANY VISAS HE
COULD AND WAS STILL WRITING
THEM ON THE TRAIN PLATFORM AS
HE WAS DEPARTING. LITHUANIA IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
YEARS AFTER THE SOVIET INVASION
OF LITHUANIA. HE WAS ASKED HIS
REASONS FOR ISSUING VISAS TO
JEWS. FOR THE HEARTS PLANE THAT
THE REFUGEES WERE HUMAN BEINGS.
THEY SIMPLY NEEDED HELP HERE'S
WHAT HE SAID. YOU WANT TO KNOW
MY MOTIVATION DON'T YOU WELL
IT'S KIND OF SENTIMENT THAT
ANYONE WOULD HAVE WE ACTUALLY
SEES THE REFUGEES FACE TO FACE.
BEGGING WITH TEARS IN THEIR
EYES. HE JUST CANNOT HELP BUT
SYMPATHIZE WITH THEM. AMONG THE
REFUGEES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
WOMEN THEY WERE SO DESPERATE
THAT THEY WENT SO FAR AS TO
KISS MY SHOES HE SAID YES I
ACTUALLY WITNESSED SUCH SCENES
WITH MY OWN EYES ALSO. I FELT.
AT THE TIME. THE JAPANESE
GOVERNMENT DID NOT HAVE ANY
UNIFORM OPINION IN TOKYO SOME
JAPANESE MILITARY LEADERS WERE
JUST SCARED. BECAUSE THE
PRESSURE FROM THE **** WHILE
OTHER OFFICIALS IN THE HOME THE
HOME MINISTRY WHICH SIMPLY
INVALID PEOPLE IN TOKYO WERE
NOT UNITED I FELT IT'S SILLY TO
DEAL WITH THEM SO I MADE UP MY
MIND NOT TO WAIT FOR THE REPLY
I KNEW THAT SOMEBODY WOULD
SURELY COMPLAIN TO ME. ABOUT
THIS IN THE FUTURE. BUT I
MYSELF THOUGHT THAT THIS WOULD
BE THE RIGHT THING TO DO. THERE
IS NOTHING WRONG. WE'RE SAVING
ON SO MANY PEOPLE'S LIVES AS
POSSIBLE THE SPIRIT OF HUMANITY
PHILANTHROPY NEIGHBORLY
FRIENDSHIP. WITH THE SPIRIT I
VENTURE TO DO WHAT I DID
CONFRONTING THIS MOMENT THIS
DIFFICULT MOMENT AND BECAUSE OF
THIS REASON I WENT AHEAD WITH
THREE DOUBLE THE COURAGE BE
DOUBLING COURAGE. SURE THE HARA.
WAS. AN EXTRAORDINARY
INDIVIDUAL AND AS WE STAND HERE
TODAY IN THIS EXTRAORDINARY
HALL IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE HONOR HIS COURAGE.
HIS EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTION
WITH THIS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NUMBER FORTY SEVEN.
DESIGNATING TODAY CHILLAI
TWENTY NINE TWO THOUSAND ONE IT
SHOULD BE HARDER. BUT THE VISA
DAY. THREE HARA. WHICH IS MORE
THIS IS A SMALL TOKEN TO YOU
SIR AND YOUR FAMILY. FOR YOUR
GREAT HUMANITY. I ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND SENATORS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
TOO AM RIGHT HONORED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR FORTY
SEVEN. AND I THINK MY GOOD
FRIENDS IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR RECOGNIZING HER OAK
WORK OF CIGAR. SHE OWNER.
BECAUSE OF HIM THOUSANDS OF
DISPLACED JEWS WERE ABLE TO
ESCAPE PERSECUTION DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. CIGARS ACTIONS WERE
NOT BASED ON RACE RELIGION OR
NATIONALITY THEY WERE DRIVEN BY
HUMANITY AND DECENCY. CIGAR
HELP FOSTER STRONG BONDS
BETWEEN JAPAN JAPANESE
AMERICANS AND JEWISH AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES THAT CONTINUE TO
THIS DAY. SUGIHARA WAS A TRUE
HUMANITARIAN AND SHOWED US THE
IMPACT THAT EVEN A SINGLE
PERSON CAN HALF IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST INJUSTICE. AND WE MUST
ASK OURSELVES WHAT EACH OF US
HAVE THE COURAGE TO DO THE SAME
IN A FIGHT AGAINST HATE. HI
SPEC WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR S. C. R. ONE FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE BAIT ON THIS
ITEM SIR- DORADO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
BRONZE STATUE OF MR SUGIHARA IN
LITTLE TOKYO AND THAT'S IN MY
DISTRICT ACTUALLY IT'S IN THE
HEART OF OUR JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AND SEVERAL YEARS
AGO I ALWAYS VISITED THE AREA
AND RAN INTO THE STATUE WITH MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS AND IT SEEMS SO
INNOCUOUS HE'S SITTING THERE IN
THIS PARK BENCH WITH. WHATNOT I
KNOW IS A VISA IN HIS HANDS.
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL THAT HIS
STATUTE IS THERE TO BRING
AWARENESS OF HIS COURAGE IN THE
FACE OF EVIL. I FOR ONE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE STATUES AND
MEMORIALS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
COMMEMORATING OUR API LEADERS.
CIGARS COURAGE IN USING HIS
POSITION TO HELP THOUSANDS OF
JEWISH FAMILIES. CONNECTS TO
THE SAME COURAGE THAT IS
REQUIRED OF US TODAY. EVEN WHEN
IT WAS UNPOPULAR TAKEAWAY HE
PUT HIS LIFE ON THE LINE TO
HELP OTHERS. I SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION TODAY ON A C. R.
FORTY SEVEN. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. MR SENATOR HERTZBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING COMMON SENSE FROM MY
BOOK FROM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON. HI I'M SORRY
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE.
HEARING C. NINE OZ THIRTY
SEVEN. KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NON MEMBERS WERE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR I HERE'S SENATOR WAY
SHOW HAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT SOON
ANYWAY SO FOR GEORGE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT OF THE PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- TODAY- HERE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IS VERY
HONORED. TO WELCOME THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LOCAL MORE
LOCAL MEXICO OR THE MAYOR AS WE
KNOW IT HERE. MEXICO THEY CALL
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE TOWN OR
THE CITY. OF SARASOTA FRANCISCO
BY THE- TRAVIS IS HERE JOINING
US IN THE GALLERY. OF. WELCOME
MR MAYOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. PRESIDENT ALICIA
JOHNSON WE BLESSED THAT I
SHOULD THE OF THE SEAT AND IT'S
ORGANISED ALTHOUGH HE HAS BEEN
ALMOST KISS ALL OF US ARE GOING
TO PASS ON. AND FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE CENTERS LIKE LOCAL. IS
CITY AND CARLY'S CALL MEXICO
OUTSIDE OF ITS PLENTIFUL
TOURIST ATTRACTIONS. IT'S
FAMOUS FOR CLOTHING
MANUFACTURING ALSO AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURING IS A IS A BIG- A
COMPLAIN OF THEIR ECONOMY. AND
A LOT OF FOOD MANUFACTURING AND
CONFECTIONARIES A LOT OF THE
CANDIES THAT ARE WITH THAT ARE
CONSUMED HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
A LOT OF THOSE PRODUCTS ARE
DESTINED. FOR OUR STATE WE
ENJOY. VERY PRODUCTIVE- TOURIST
OR OR ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIP
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS.
THANK YOU. AND SINCE WE'RE
STILL UNDER PROVISIONS OF
FLORIDA FOR OTHER ANNOUNCEMENT
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL BIRTHDAY
GREETING TODAY AND THAT'S T.
MATTHEW BURNS MATT THROUGH
LET'S SAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY R. R.
SIDENT MINUTE CLARK SO HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO YOU TODAY AS WELL
CONSIDER WHAT. OUR MEMBERS WERE
MOVING BACK TO. CONSIDERATION
OF THE FILE NOW WERE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING WE HAVE FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN VICE SENATOR COM
AUGER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
ITEM. AND SHE'S PREPARING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR COM WALKER AN ACT
RELATING TO REST WARRANTS.
SENATOR COME OVER THE FLOOR
GEORGE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING. TO YOU AND
MEMBERS I AM PRESENTING AB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH AMENDS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PENAL CODE TO
PERMIT AN EMPLOYEE OF A PUBLIC
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE TO PRESENT
A PROBABLE CAUSE DETERMINATION
TO A JUDGE. AND SEEKING AN
ARREST WARRANT IN CASES WHEN
THE SUBJECT IS A PEACE OFFICER
THE AIM IS SIMPLY TO REDUCE
PROCEDURAL BARRIERS TO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY BY ELIMINATING
ONE OF THEM- FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND INITIATING
PROSECUTIONS AGAINST MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WILL CLARIFY THAT
A DECLARATION OF PROBABLE CAUSE
FOR AN ARREST WARRANT. NEED NOT
BE PROVIDED ONLY BY A PEACE
OFFICER BUT COULD ALSO BE
PROVIDED BY A PROSECUTOR. THE
PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW MAKES NO
OTHER CHANGES TO THE PROCESS OF
OBTAINING AN ARREST WARRANT
BEYOND THE EXPANSION OF
POSSIBLE OFFENSE BEYOND PEACE
OFFICERS IT WOULD NOT CHANGE
THE PROBABLE CAUSE STANDARD OF
PROOF AND JUDGES WOULD STILL
RETAIN THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE
AN ARREST WARRANT. EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN IS SUPPORTED BY
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS IT
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FALL ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. IN
NINETEEN NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS. BASE
BACKER. FIVE FOUR NO BRADFORD
HI CABRERA. CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD HI TORONTO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. HI THE MON. HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW BOTH.
HI CAN I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN HI
NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI I WINNER.
I WILL NO. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. AT KINS.
BATES NO. BY ADAM I. HER TADO.
MELINDA'S SKINNER. MARCH TWENTY
NINE NOTES SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS NOW IS THE TIME
FOR COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT
SOONER PORN CHANNEL. THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN FORTY TWO OH THREE- AT
TEN O'CLOCK. OR TEN O'CLOCK THE
APPROPRIATIONS WILL MEET IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE CINNABAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH MRPRESIDENT
THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT TEN TEN
WILL MEET AT TEN TEN IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. CONTENT
GOVERNANCE FINANCE WILL MEET IN
A ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AT
TEN TEN. I TALKED TO A SENIOR
BOARD YOU KNOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS AT
DOING IT HALF HOUR BETWEEN. TEN
FIFTEEN AT TEN FIFTEEN
PRESIDENT OF OPERATIONS WILL
MEET HERE IN THE CHAMBER THANK
YOU. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO A RETURNING TO MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME
FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORIES.
SENATOR THERE ALSO ARE YOU
PREPARED. YESTHANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I ASK WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF LINDA
THEN. PASSED AWAY ON MAY THIRTY
FIRST AT SIXTY EIGHT YEARS OLD
YOUNG FROM CANCER. SHE WAS THE
FIRST WOMAN AND THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN. TO LEAD THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCAL SEVEN TO ONE. WHICH
IS THE LARGEST PUBLIC SECTOR
UNION IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS BORN IN LOUISIANA AND
RAISED IN COMPTON WHERE SHE
WITNESSED FIRST HAND THE DEEP
AND WIDESPREAD EFFECTS OF
RACISM IT WAS THEN SHE DECIDED
TO DEDICATE HER LIFE TO
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE. HE
WAS AN ACTIVE LEADER IN
CAMPAIGNS THAT SECURED
SIGNIFICANT WINS FOR WORKING
CLASS ANGELENOS AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR SHE HELPED ORGANIZE
SUPPORT AND COALITION NEEDED ON
THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN CAMPAIGN
IN LOS ANGELES CULMINATED IN
VICTORIES AT THE CITY COUNTY
AND ULTIMATELY. THE STATE LEVEL
RAISING WAGES FOR ALMOST SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS SHE ALSO
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO OPEN UP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WELL PAID
JOBS TO THOSE WHO OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED. SHE
HELPED FOUND THE COMPANY JOBS
FAIR TO HELP FORMERLY
INCARCERATED ANGELENOS HE WAS
PIVOTAL IN PUSHING THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES TO CREATE THE PACT
TARGETED LOCAL HIRE PROGRAM. IT
WAS AN INNOVATIVE PROGRAM THAT
SET ASIDE ENTRY LEVEL PUBLIC
JOBS FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER
ANGELENOS FROM UNDERSERVED
BACKGROUNDS. I REMEMBER HER AS
ENERGETIC AND UNRELENTING AS A
WOMAN AND A WOMAN OF COLOR I AM
SO PROUD AND PRIVILEGED THAT I
WAS ABLE TO KNOW HER AND WORK
WITH HER. SHE DEDICATED HERSELF
TO ORGANIZED LABOR BECAUSE HE
TRULY BELIEVED IN THE POWER OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. AS A WAY
TO UPLIFT WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
AND SHRINK THE GAP BETWEEN THE
RICH AND THE POOR HER LEGACY
WILL BE DEFINED AS A FEARLESS
CHAMPION CHAMPION FOR WORKING
PEOPLE. WE ALL AGREE WE LOST
LINDA TOO SOON REST IN POWER
SISTER LINDA DONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR RATHER
POWERFUL LABOR LEADER AND
BRINGING FORWARD SO IT CAN BE
PROPERLY ADJOURNED. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR TROY BOOK
REPAIR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
I RIDE THROUGH JOURNEY RIGHT.
CENTER LEVEL HERE A TROUBLED
YOUR MIKE ON THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. TESTING TESTING.
TESTING. WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU AND THEN
IT. I RICE RETURN IN MEMORY OF
SERGEANT DOMINICK BACA WHO IS
THE DECISION OF MINE FROM
YUCAIPA. ON MONDAY MAY THIRTY
FIRST SURGEON DOCTOR WAS SHOT
IN THE LINE. OF DUTY WHILE
ASSISTING DEPUTIES FROM THE
MORONGO BASIN STATION IN A FOOT
PURSUIT. SURGEON DR LATER
SUCCUMBED TO HIS INJURIES IN
THE HOSPITAL WHAT'S AROUND IT
BY HIS LOVED ONES AND MEMBERS
OF HIS LAW ENFORCEMENT FAMILY.
THIRTEEN BACK I BEGAN HIS
CAREER AS A DEPUTY SHERIFF IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. AS THE DEPUTY HE WORK
CORRECTIONS AND PATROL AT
CENTRAL STATION. HE WAS LATER
PROMOTED TO THE NARCOTICS
DIVISION AS A DETECTIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN. IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
HE WAS PROMOTED TO SERGEANT AT
WEST VALLEY DETENTION CENTER IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HE WAS ASSIGNED TO THE MORONGO
BASIN STATION. WHERE HE SERVED
THECOMMUNITY WITH GREAT PRIDE
AND PROFESSIONALISM. SURGEON
BACK I SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
VALERIE. IN TWO DAUGHTERS. HIS
MOTHER DOROTHY STEPFATHER JAMES
WILLIAMS FATHER DAVID BROTHER
DAMIEN AND BROTHER IN LAW
MICHAEL SO THAT'S NOT. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SERGEANT DOMINICK
BACA FOR HIS MANY YEARS OF
SERVICE HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED. THANK YOU SENATOR-
TROUBLE. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED AS
SENATOR GROWTH. AT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I JOIN THE
SENATOR FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE
TO CHURN IN THE MEMORY OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
SERGEANT DOMINICK BACA. WHO WAS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY JUST
LAST MONTH. SERGEANT BAKA
WORKED FOR THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY SHERIFF FOR MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN YEARS. AND IN THAT
TIME HERE IN THE TRUST AND LOVE
OF ALL THOSE THAT HE PROTECTED
AND SERVED. HE PROVED HIMSELF
AS A VALUABLE MEMBER OF THIS
COMMUNITY THROUGH HIS MANY
ROLES AT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT STARTING AS A DEPUTY
SHERIFF AND WORKING HIS WAY UP
TO WITH DISTINCTION. TO THE
SERGEANT WORKING IN THE MORONGO
BASIN STATION IN MY DISTRICT.
HIS LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY
TRAGICALLY TAKEN DURING A
ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP. WELL IN A
FOOT PURSUIT IN THE DESERT THE
SUSPECT LAID IN WAIT. AS
OFFICERS CAME ACROSS THE HILL.
THE SHOTS WERE FIRED. SERGE
IBAKA WAS STRUCK. AND LATER
SUCCUMBED TO HIS INJURIES
INJURIES STARTED BACK AS LIFE
WAS TAKEN FAR TOO SOON AND
THOUGH WE WILL MOURN WITH MOURN
HIM WE ARE ALSO GRATEFUL FOR
THE LIFE THAT HE LIVED EVERY
DAY. LIKE SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES
AND OFFICERS EVERYWHERE WE
PARTNER WHO PROUDLY DONNED THE
UNIFORM AND RECITED THE OATH TO
DO EVERYTHING HE COULD TO
PROTECT AND SERVE THE COMMUNITY
BUT HE WAS ASSIGNED TO. HE WAS
A PROUD FATHER HUSBAND AND SON.
THE LOST HIS FAMILY HAS ENDURED
IS UNTHINKABLE. WE EXTEND OUR
LOVE AND PRAYERS HIS WIFE
VALERIE HIS TWO DAUGHTERS AND
HIS ENTIRE FAMILY IN THE MEN
AND WOMEN. THEY HAVE THE
COURAGE SPECIFICALLY IN THESE
DAYS TO CONTINUE TO PUT ON A
UNIFORM TO PROTECT AND SERVE
OUR CONSTITUENTS. WE MOURN WITH
THIS FAMILY AND ASK GOD TO JUST
WRAP HIS LOVING ARMS AROUND HIS
WIFE HIS FAMILY- AND THE
OFFICERS THAT HE SERVED WITH.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY ARE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF A LA LUMINARY THE
BUSINESSMAN EXTRAORDINAIRE THAT
IN THE PERSON OF FRED ANTHONY
CALLOWAY. MR CALLAWAY WAS ONE
OF THE FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK MEN OF LOS
ANGELES AND HE WAS A MAJOR
CATALYST FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDER REPRESENTED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. MR KELLER WAS
BORN IN NEW ORLEANS LOUISIANA.
BUT HE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA AND
HE BECAME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN BUYER FOR PARKER
BROTHERS FOR HOME FURNISHINGS.
STARTING IN THE LAMPS MIRRORS
AND ASSESS REASON PARTS
DEPARTMENT AND LATER SUPERVISE-
DEPARTMENT IN NINETEEN. PARKER
BROTHERS STORAGE HE LATER SAID-
BEGAN ACCEPTS A CAREER AS A
MANUFACTURER'S REPRESENTATIVE
WHERE HE REPRESENTED IT
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEE TRAINING
CHEERED HIS EXPERTISE WITH
OTHERS TO INCREASE SALES OF
SEVERAL SO THREE MANUFACTURERS
ON THE EAST AND WEST COAST IF
YOU'VE GONE INTO ANY OF THE
MAJORS DEPARTMENT STORE THE
ROLLOUT FORTY YEARS AND YOU SAW
THE AMAZING DISPLAYS THAT WERE
SET THERE THAT WAS TO WORK FOR
MR CALLAWAY. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN
FOR HIS BUSINESS DOCUMENT IN
HIS PROFESSIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HIS PHILOSOPHY
WAS YOU MUST BE CREATIVE AND
STRIVE FOR CHANGE BY CONSTANTLY
UPGRADING YOUR THINKING BECAUSE
IF YOU ONLY KEEP UP WITH THE
TRENDS. TO GENERATE SOMETHING
NEW. I KNEW I SHOULD SAY THEN
YOUR WORK IS GOING TO BE VERY
DOLL. MR CALLAWAY ALSO FOUNDED.
BC TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CORPORATION WHAT IS SIGNED MY
GOOD FRIEND DR ANTHONY CALLOWAY
AND DAVID BELASCO- THE
CORPORATION SPECIALIZE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL GEOLOGICAL
DRILLING WHILE OPERATING WITH
INTEGRITY PROFESSIONALISM AND
SAFETY. HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT
AND CEO WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF OVERALL MANAGEMENT AND
OPERATIONS. OF THE COMPANY WITH
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON
MARKETING AND BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT PERSONNEL FINANCE
AND FINANCIAL MATTERS MR
CALLAWAY WAS ALSO TO FIND
FUNDING PRESIDENT AND BOARD
MEMBER OF THE SELLER FELT
SOMETHING CALIFORNIA. DRILLERS
ASSOCIATION. BUT BEGINNING IN
AT NINETEEN. SEVENTY SIX MR
CALLAWAY PURCHASED THE REASON
SHE WATCHED. HE FACILITY IN
LAMAR PARK IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH LA IF YOU'VE BEEN IN LA
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS YOU HAVE
GONE SOME AT ONE POINT FOUR
EIGHT CONTINUA A BULL.
DEBUTANTES A GREAT DINNER
FUNDRAISER FOR PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE YOU NAME IT- IT WAS
HOSTED AT THE REGENCY WAS A
CENTER THAT MR CALLAWAY IST OWN
STILL THIS DAY IN WHICH PROFIT
CENTER BUT IF YOU WERE A FAN OF
THE EMERGING BLACK COMEDY IN
THE LOW EIGHTIES AND EARLY
NINETIES IT WAS THERE AT THE
REGENCY WHAT'S THERE THAT WAS
CONVERTED TO THE COMEDY ACT.
THERE WERE. I MERRY- COMEDY
GREATS LIKE ROBIN HARRIS WAS
DISCOVERED JAMIE FOXX BEFORE
WE- WAS THERE EVER A MOVIE- KIM
WHITLEY I CAN GO ON AND ON THE
WINNINGS BROTHERS- THEY ALL
PERFORM THERE IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES AND EARLY NINETIES AND
IT WAS DUE TO MR FOR.
CALLAWAY'S GENEROSITY OF MAKING
THAT FACILITY AVAILABLE TO THE
PROMOTER- MICHAEL WILLIAMS-
THAT WE MIGHT NOT HAVE NEVER
KNOWN ANY OF THESE GREAT COMICS
THAT. OUR TV AND MOVIE SCREENS
TODAY. MR CALLAWAY IS A HUSBAND
HE WAS A FATHER. IS A
GRANDFATHER FATHER IN LAW AND
JUST A GOOD ALL AROUND GOOD
FRIEND. HE WAS A DEAR FRIEND
AND MENTOR TO ME WHEN I JOINED
THE ONE HUNDRED BLACK MEN. OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO HE WELCOMED
ME WITH OPEN ARMS AND ALWAYS
HAD WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT AND
GUIDANCE FOR ME. AND IT'S ONLY
ONE THING THAT I REGRET OVER
THE YEARS IF YOU THINK WILLIE
BROWN IS IT EXQUISITE PRESSER.
THEN YOU NEED TO SEE FRED
CALLAWAY WHO WAS HE WAS BY THE
ONLY PERSON I KNOW. WHO COULD
RIVAL WILLIE BROWN AND HE
ALWAYS SAID LITTLE BROTHER.
COME OVER TO THE HOUSE I HAVE A
CLOSET FULL OF SUITS BUT I WANT
TO GIVE YOU AND I NEVER TOOK
HIM UP ON THAT AND HE WOULD
ALWAYS KNOWS ME LET ME KNOW. IF
I WAS GAINING A LITTLE WEIGHT
IS A LITTLE BROTHER PRETTY SOON
YOU WILL GO TO FIT THOSE SUITS
SO YOU BETTER COME ON OVER TO
THE HOUSE. AND I WAS
NEIGHBORHOOD NEVER ABLE TO TIE
NEVER TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THAT
BUT HE WAS EXQUISITE DRESSER
ALWAYS A BEAUTIFUL HAT ON HIS
HEAD AND JUST ALL ALL ALL
AROUND THIS GREAT. MAN YOU WILL
BE KNOWN FOR HIS CONFIDANT. HE
WAS A CONFIDANT TO SO MANY
ADVISER AS I STATED IN A HERO
TO MANY YOUNG ADULTS INCLUDING
MYSELF AND A MENTOR HE WAS
COMBINE WITH A SPEAR CARRYING
DEMEANOR AND A DEDICATION TO.
THE BETTER LIVES OF SO MANY
AROUND HIM AND HE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED AND WE WERE
BLESSED TO CALL MY FRIEND WAS
BLESSED TO HAVE THEM HERE IN.
LOS ANGELES IN CALIFORNIA AND
HE'S A GREAT AMERICAN HE'LL BE
MISSED BY HIS AMAZING WIFE
EUGENIA. AND HIS SON ANTHONY
HIS DAUGHTER MANY OF YOU GET NO
JOB THE NASA BILL CALLAWAY THE
ACTORS AND IT'S TOO AMAZING
GRANDDAUGHTERS ASHLEY. AND
ALEXANDER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO JOURNEY. MEMBER OF FRED
ANTHONY CAL. THANK YOU SENATOR.
PLEASE BRING HIS FORWARD SO HE
MAY BE PROPER MORE. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE DISK IS
CLEARLY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT SHOULD FOR I
DEAL WITH THE. BUSINESS OF THE
HOUSE I WANTED TO JUST MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT TO CONGRATULATE
OUR BUDGET CHAIR SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY WHO LAST NIGHT BECAME
A BRAND NEW GRANDMOTHER FOR THE
FIRST TIME. TWO LITTLE RONIN
WHEN YOU GET IN MEMBERS AT NINE
POUNDS FOUR OUNCES NEW MOM
SHARON IS DOING WELL AND WE ALL
WANT TO CONGRATULATE HER AND
WISH EVERYONE- WISH EVERYONE
THE BEST AND WITH THAT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
FIVE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE PM
AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE
MEMBERS.